il ya quelques semaines je vous ai
invités à voter pour la présidentielle
2022 sur la plateforme tournesol avec le
scrutin de tournesol et bien après
quelques semaines de vote j'ai le
plaisir de vous annoncer que le
vainqueur de cette élection est
alors avant de vous révéler le résultat
j'ouvre une petite parenthèse sur la
participation il ya eu 4 1922
participants qui ont contribué un total
de 39 1850 et une comparaison bien
entendu la plupart des participations
font suite à ma vidéo ce qui signifie
que le vainqueur de l'élection
présentielle tournesol et la vente ou le
candidat préféré par la communauté des
spectateurs 200 vols qui sont
suffisamment se motiver pour voter sur
tournesol il s'agit clairement d'un
échantillon extrêmement biaisée de la
population française bien sûr si toute
la population française avait voté il
faudrait s'attendre à des résultats très
différents néanmoins en tout cas pour le
youtube heures que je suis là vie
poétique de la communauté qui me suit et
est motivé pour aller participer à
tournesol c'est bien sûr quelque chose
que je trouve néanmoins très intéressant
et justement le candidat que cette
communauté préfère c'est
avant de vous donner la réponse je me
permet d'ouvrir une deuxième temps thèse
l'objectif du scrutin un tournesol pour
la présidentielle n'est bien sûr pas de
proposer une alternative à l'élection
présidentielle française pour les
institutions en fait dès souhaitant plus
simples sont beaucoup plus adéquat pour
cet objectif restreint comme le vote par
approbation le jugement majoritaire où
les scrutins de condenser randomisés
mais ce serait je pense ne grave erreur
que de penser que la gouvernance d'un
pays voire de toute l'humanité ne se
joue que lors de scrutins présidentiels
ou même législatif une fois tous les
cinq ans ou quelques fois par an
seulement dans les sociétés extrêmement
complexe dans lesquelles nous vivons il
ya des milliers des millions voire des
milliards de décisions qui nous implique
en fait tous comme par exemple les
contenus informationnels qui sont
massivement recommander à nos
compatriotes voire à des milliards
d'humains dans des pays étrangers dont
les croyances peuvent affecter la
bienveillance ou la haine que ces
humains peuvent ressentir envers vous et
votre famille particulier j'insiste une
fois de plus sur le fait que la
diffusion de l'information n'est
absolument pas un problème qui ne
concerne que le producteur le diffuseur
et le consommateur l'information
produite diffusée est consommée en
russie aujourd'hui est en train de
menacer la sécurité et le bien-être de
40 millions craignant ailleurs dans le
monde le marché de l'information pose
des problèmes de sécurité et de paix à
l'échelle planétaire les dés lors urgent
qu'on dispose de moyens de gouvernance
de l'information qu'ils soient
collaboratif auditables et sécurisé tel
est précisément l'objectif à long terme
de tournesol en cela tournesol pour la
présidentielle c'est davantage un
prototype pédagogique pour initier des
milliers d'entre vous à ce que tournesol
envisage pour la gouvernance de
l'information à l'échelle planétaire est
le grand enjeu à court terme pour
tourner au sol c'est en fait même
davantage de vous convaincre de
participer à tourner au sol pour les
vidéos pour nous permettre de construire
la première base de données publique du
grande échelle et sécurisée qui
contiennent une grande variété de
jugement éthique d'humains et pour qu'il
soit enfin possible d'identifier ce qui
fait clairement débat est ce qui fait
clairement consensus et d'ailleurs dans
le cas de la présidentielle 2022 le
consensus qui se dégage ou au sein de la
communauté des contributeurs c'est que
le meilleur président aurait été
alors je vais ouvrir une troisième et je
vous le promets dernière parenthèse
l'expérience tourne au sol pour la
présidentielle est aussi intéressante
pour nous chez tournesol en tant que
développeur promoteurs et même aussi en
tant que expérimentateur de la
plateforme en particulier nous
souhaitons documenté autant que possible
l'expérience pour permettre aux
chercheurs aux journalistes et aux
curieux parmi vous de mieux comprendre
l'impact du vote à la tournesol sur les
électeurs ainsi que sur ce qu'on peut
tirer d'un tel vote mais pour faire cela
nous avons besoin de davantage
d'informations sur les participants au
vote tournesol c'est pour ça que je vais
encore vous sollicitez en vous demandant
de bien vouloir répondre également aux
sondages que j'ai mis dans la
description et en commentaire épinglés
ceci nous permettra de mieux comprendre
les biais de nos données mais aussi de
mieux documenter l'expérience des
votants parmi vous j'en profite pour
remercier profondément tous ceux qui
parmi vous ont participé à tournesol ou
participeront à tournesol à l'avenir et
plus encore ceux qui parmi vous
encourager voire convaincu d'autres
parmi votre entourage à s'intéresser aux
aussi à tournesol au nom de toute
l'équipe tourne au sol que je salue au
passage et que je remercie également je
vous dis merci merci à tous merci de
nous aider à avancer la réflexion sur la
gouvernance mondiale de l'information
bref
à ces paris laissez moi enfin vous
présenter le vainqueur de la
présidentielle 2022 sur tournesol le
candidat préféré par la communauté des
contributeurs et selon notre scrutin
c'est jean luc mélenchon j'ai envie de
lui dire félicitations même si je sais
pas s'il va beaucoup s'intéresser au
résultat de ce vote je vous invite par
ailleurs à jeter un oeil sur notre site
web pour voir les classements des
différents candidats non seulement selon
le critère principal mais aussi selon
les critères secondaires comme par
exemple politique internationale et bien
sûr je vous invite aussi et avant tout à
contribuer à notre plateforme en
comparant surtout les vidéos candidate à
être des vidéos reconnue d'utilité
publique selon la communauté des
contributeurs de tournesol je vous
remercie pour cela infiniment davance